[Música]
a 10 años de prisión fue sentenciada la
ex presidenta interina de bolivia de
línea y es tras ser juzgada por los
delitos de incumplimiento de deberes y
resoluciones contrarias a la
constitución la funcionaria había
reiterado su inocencia y descendido que
volvería a tomar las decisiones que tomó
durante la crisis de 2019 en su país
ampliamos desde la paz
durante la jornada de cierre de la
cumbre de las américas 20 países del
continente entre ellos eeuu y méxico
firmaron la llamada declaración de los
ángeles sobre emigración y protección
con compromisos que buscan contener la
crisis migratoria en la región el texto
determina que ninguna nación debe asumir
sola esta responsabilidad tenemos
recortes desde los ángeles
continúa el avance por territorio
mexicano de la caravana de migrantes que
este viernes llegó a mapastepec el grupo
se ha fragmentado y muchos siguen
esperando visas temporales para
transitar por territorio mexicano
tenemos ampliación
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 soy valentina
torre sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos en bolivia donde el tribunal
primero de sentencia
anticorrupción de la ciudad de la paz
condenó a la ex presidenta interina
jeanine áñez a 10 años de cárcel la ex
funcionaria fue juzgada por los delitos
de incumplimiento de deberes y
resoluciones contrarias a la
constitución
mery vaca corresponsal de france 24 en
bolivia nos explicó los detalles de este
juicio por el caso denominado golpe de
estado 2 que se produjo por delitos
cometidos antes de que años asumiera sus
funciones como mandataria interina la ex
presidenta interina de bolivia jeanine
áñez ha sido sentenciada a 10 años de
cárcel que debe cumplir en el penal de
miraflores de la ciudad de la paz hasta
el 10 de julio de
2032 eso ha dicho el tribunal esta noche
en cuanto a la sentencia de la
expresidenta jeanine áñez y
evidentemente ella ha sido sentenciada
por los actos cometidos supuestamente
antes que asumiera el mando del país
concretamente en los dos días previos
comprendidos entre el 10 de noviembre de
2019 cuando se produjo la renuncia del
ex presidente evo morales y el 12 de
noviembre de 2019 cuando ella ya nine
años asumió la presidencia del país
luego de un vacío de poder también han
sido sentenciados esta noche los
miembros del alto mando militar que en
ese momento estaban habían pedido la
renuncia de evo morales
concretamente williams kalimán que fue
el comandante en jefe de las fuerzas
armadas ha sido también sentenciado a 10
años de cárcel otros miembros de este
alto mando militar han sido sentenciados
y condenados a penas menores entre 2 y 3
años porque ellos previamente se han
declarado culpables en este proceso en
la ciudad estadounidense de los ángeles
se llevó a cabo el último día de la
cumbre de las américas desde allí
natalia cabrera enviada especial de
france 24 nos dio más detalles de esta
jornada
20 países de américa firmaron la
declaración final de los ángeles este es
el documento que resume los acuerdos
alcanzados durante esta novena cumbre de
las américas entre los jefes de estado y
de gobierno que se reunieron aquí en el
centro de convenciones durante toda una
semana el principal acuerdo llegó en
materia de emigración en acciones
tangibles para responder a este problema
dentro del continente sin embargo la
única acción concreta que se tomará en
este aspecto fue la anunciada por la
vicepresidenta de eeuu kamala harris al
principio de esta semana durante la
cumbre de sí y los directores ejecutivos
de empresas estadounidenses que se
comprometieron a donar a invertir mejor
1900 millones de dólares en el triángulo
norte de centroamérica esto es honduras
el salvador y guatemala con el fin de
generar empleo en estos tres países para
detener la migración hacia el norte del
continente las siguientes medidas
anunciadas dentro de esta declaración de
la cumbre de las américas son más bien
intangibles y se le da la potestad a
cada uno de los países
decidir cómo implementarlas esto se
trata de reforzar la seguridad
fronteriza según cada una de las leyes
de los países que integran nuestro
continente así como al crear un programa
para atender las emergencias y los
desastres naturales y finalmente
implementar y otorgar un camino hacia la
migración legal y protección para los
refugiados sin que se anuncien medidas
concretas de cómo se va a llevar a cabo
este programa finalmente eeuu también
anunció que va a ser una donación de
ayudas por 300 millones de dólares a
todos los países receptores de
refugiados inmigrantes venezolanos
la caravana migrante que el lunes salió
de tapachula en el sur de méxico llegó
hasta la localidad de mapastepec el
grupo con miles de integrantes se ha ido
fragmentando en diferentes sectores
andrés suárez periodista de france 24
explicó qué tan rápido avanza el proceso
de legalización del estatus migratorio
de acuerdo con mi rey garcía villagrán a
que todos los migrantes conocen como el
abogado y quien es el líder de esta
caravana ha dado una nueva información y
es que al día de hoy te han entregado en
las oficinas de aduanas de huixtla un
promedio de 8 mil partes migratorios que
avalan a los migrantes para que puedan
estar con 30 días libremente transitando
mente sin el temor de ser deportados
luego de meses de travesía y el temor de
ser capturados en centros de detención
de reclusos como el del siglo 21 en
tapachula donde han denunciado torturas
tortura mental tortura física y por lo
cual el propio líder de la caravana dice
que en los próximos días denunciarán
ante la fiscalía general de mexico a la
directora de este centro de reclusión
todavía faltan 10.000 migrantes que no
han recibido el papel migratorio y ya se
está hablando que viene una nueva
caravana con cinco mil muy grandes de
tapachula para completar los 20 mil que
se dirigirían hacia oaxaca
en colombia los sondeos indican una
apretada disputa de cara a la segunda
vuelta presidencial del 19 de junio el
candidato de izquierda gustavo petro
tendría un 48,1 por ciento de la
intención de voto mientras que rodolfo
hernández un 46 8 % ambos aspirantes
continúan su campaña en medio de
polémicas informa lluís muñoz para que
está el resultado una ventaja de menos
de dos puntos para gustavo petro son los
indicadores del último tracking
presidencial los analistas ven una
votación disputada entonces ahí podría
uno ver que hay un un match y hay una
cosa muy apretada entre entre ambos
candidatos yo creo que la elección no va
a ser definida de una manera tan holgada
el líder de izquierda gustavo petro ha
cambiado su estrategia en esta segunda
vuelta de la tarima ha bajado a la
tierra y ha estado acercándose a
ciudadanos del común en encuentros que
retransmite en redes táctica que le ha
servido para resistir en los sondeos
sin embargo revista semana publicó
vídeos internos de la campaña donde se
habla de atacar y desacreditar rivales
para dividir a la coalición centrista
derrotada en primera vuelta
ante esto alfonso prada jefe de debate
de petro acudió a los tribunales
presente personalmente denunció penal
ante la fiscalía general de la nación
para que se averigüe la magnitud de
delincuencia que está por detrás de
utilizar nuestra campaña y de afectar
las elecciones mientras tanto rodolfo
hernández está muy cerca de petro en las
encuestas sigue en miami finalmente
volverá el sábado a colombia tras haber
denunciado un plan para matarle pero la
polémica también le rodea en una
entrevista con el canal telemundo sus
asesores interrumpieron una pregunta
sobre el caso vitalogy de corrupción que
le persigue el día cuando hernán todo
esto a poco más de una semana para la
segunda vuelta del domingo 19 de junio
con nuevas revelaciones cada día pero
sin la posibilidad de un debate
descartado por la campaña de rodolfo
hernández en ucrania la batalla continua
centrada en la ciudad de severodonezk a
donde las autoridades de la región
aseguran que buscan desgastar a las
tropas rusas hasta que llegue nuevo
armamento del extranjero en el donbass
la población se enfrenta a la disyuntiva
de huir de sus hogares
en la zona los detalles en el siguiente
informe
puede que la ciudad oriental de
decisiones que sean mano ucranianas pero
el ejército ruso está convirtiendo la
vida cristiana en una miseria donde la
escasez de agua a los residentes hacen
cola frente a los camiones cisterna y
aquí conseguimos agua para lavar la ropa
para lavar los platos y recogemos el
agua potable de un manantial pero es
difícil ir allí la pendiente es muy
pronunciada y bombardean todos los días
así que tenemos que ir a ti bajo los
bombardeos bajo el fuego para algunos ya
es demasiado por lo que han decidido
marcharse
[Música]
la vida me hizo marcharme los bombardeos
constantes y también mi nieto me suplicó
ven a vernos pero no sé cómo llegar deje
su dirección en casa
las familias se están ayudando
mutuamente organizando viajes para
aquellos que necesitan transporte para
hoy las evacuaciones han alcanzado una
nueva etapa es muy difícil convencer a
la gente de que los rusos han llegado a
un punto crítico y que ya es hora de
evacuar a un lugar seguro
desde las colinas los combates en la
vecina aseveró díaz continúan
las fuerzas ucranianas están luchando
para mantener el control de la ciudad en
toda la región muchos residentes viven
ahora en sus sótanos bodegas se niegan a
abandonar sus casas por decisión propia
o por las dificultades para hacerlo
fin del informativo a ustedes gracias
por su sintonía volvemos a breve aquí en
france 24
[Música]